[Music]
first came the grasses they came in
thick
then smaller shrubs
with them the insects returned
then the trees
and with the trees the monkeys and
elephants
here at psy sanctuary we have over 300
acres of forest that we have replanted
and brought back to life
[Music]
my full name is pamela gayle malhotra
and i am co-founder with my husband
of psy sanctuary trust
it had always been our dream
to have
a private forest
sanctuary for wildlife
where they would be protected
when we first came here
most of the lands that were sold to us
were abandoned lands
abandoned rice fields coffee and ottoman
fields as well a lot of deforestation
had taken place
and that took a lot a lot of care and
energy and time and years to bring it
back they've really done well this year
they've done really well people thought
we were quite crazy but that's okay a
lot of people have thought people that
have done some amazing things are crazy
[Music]
here in the sanctuary
it is a biodiversity hot spot
i remember walking through the forest
you wouldn't hear anything but the sound
of your own feet
[Music]
now the place is alive with sound
[Music]
one of our main
sound makers
are the cicadas
they have a tremendous decibel
range
here they start again
[Music]
we keep striving to do more and more but
the initial goal has been more than
achieved
my hope for the next 10 years for this
forest
is that it will continue to be protected
and expanded
[Music]
we both feel a tremendous amount of joy
when we walk through the sanctuary
i've never felt this kind of joy
in anything else that i've done in my
life
[Music]
you